Salut à tous c'est Pêcheurs de trésors
Aujourd'hui nous sommes entre les régions du Lot et de L'Aveyron
C'est le fleuve Lot
Nous sommes avec des abonnés
Que nous avons rejoint
Parce-ce-que ils ont un super spot dans lequel ils ont déjà trouvé deux armes
Donc on s'est dit qu'on allait tester ça
Nous sommes avec Alex
ainsi que son fils Gaetan
C'est parti pour la pêche, Rasta aussi est là bien entendu
Romain et Micka vous pêchez à l'aimant depuis combien de temps ?
Je dirais 2 mois
Seulement 2 mois et vous avez déjà fait de belles découvertes
J'ai mis au moins 6 mois avant de trouver ma première arme
Sans compter la première
Sans compter celle avec l'aimant Wish
Regardez cet abonné chanceux les gars !
Premier lancer !
Alors ça ce n'est pas un pistolet à silex
C'est un pistolet de poche à coffre
Avec un seul coup
Et le rechargement se fait par la bouche
C'est magique, comment il fait ?
C'est pas possible, regardez moi ça
Il est en super état, totalement restaurable aussi
Il est légèrement abîmé là
ça date des années 1850 ce type de pistolets
Félicitations Romain, Bravo
Non gardez le
Du coup il nous le donne, on va le restaurer !
Il suffit de mettre une amorce en haut, ici
Puis tu mets la poudre et la balle
Dis la vérité, t'es passé déposer des trucs avant qu'on arrive
C'est fou de trouver ça dans un endroit si perdu
C'est fou
Par contre la pêche à l'aimant ce n'est pas trouver une arme si facilement à chaque fois
non non non
Il y a de la chance là
Alors là nous sommes bloqués sur quelque chose de très gros
On va utiliser tous les bras disponibles alors
A peu de choses près
vas y on peut essayer comme ça
Ah c'est bon, il y a bien quelque chose alors
Il y a un truc, regarde toutes les bulles qui arrivent
C'est bon signe
j'espère que c'est un coffre fort
Ou même une moto
Oh la vache, c'est lourd
En plus ça se coince dans le bord
Vous allez tirer toutes les racines avec
Allez bien joué
C'est bien, mais personne n'a réussi à pronostiquer l'objet
Là il reste encore un gros morceau
Vous êtes prêts ?
Allez
Aahaha
ça vient
On dirait une bite d'amarrage
Il y a un autre aimant de disponible ?
C'est une bite d'amarrage avec encore du câble d'acier autour
L'aimant de secours arrive
Je ne sais pas ou est Rasta, il a disparu depuis quelques minutes
Il doit embêter les pêcheurs de poissons
Non il est là, le pauvre
Ah il dort
1,2,3
Ah oui c'est un beau morceau !
Romain est en pleine forme !
Bien joué
Même si ce n'est pas totalement terminé
Baptiste tu pourras faire de la muscu dans le garage
Oui on a une bonne altère là
C'est une sacré altère même
Parfait, bien joué
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
C'est difficile à dire
Il y a plein de choses ici mais elles sont difficiles d'accès
Qu'est-ce que c'est encore ?
Il y a plein de choses
Alors on a :
Une cuillère
En bon état
En Inox, je rappelle que certains aciers inoxydables réagissent à l'aimant
Ensuite on a ce gros machin
Heureusement il est creux
Sûrement une partie de cadre de mobylette
Si il n'y avait pas toutes ces branches là
Dommage nous n'avons pas emmené la machette
Celui-là est plus lourd que les autres
Oh purée c'est une jante
Il reste des lambeaux de caoutchouc
C'est sportif aujourd'hui
Les pros reconnaitront le type de voiture
Je ne sais pas à quoi ça correspond
Ola qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Un appareil électrique
C'est toi qui a sorti tous ces trucs pourris ?
Ouais
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est un vieux batteur ça
Tu mets les fouets ici
Ah oui ok
Et ça, une pile ou batterie ?
Non ça c'est une bobine d'allumage de mobylette
Ok
Il a y plein de trucs, même si je me bats avec les plantes
C'est le genre d'endroit ou ils devaient tout jeter dans les années 1970
J'ai un taille haie
Carrément
T'es bloqué ? Ouais
Ah mais tu l'as vraiment avec toi en plus ?
Alors on va l'utiliser
En vrai on pourrait couper un peu
ne tombe pas à l'eau
Ah oui ça coupe bien
Là j'ai de la boue
Regardez cette équipe de pêcheurs à l'aimant en haut de leur bute
Ah un couteau
Un demi couteau
Non il est presque neuf
C'est presque neuf pour toi ça ?
Il est totalement mort
C'est quoi le morceau bleu là ?
C'est une cuillère, j'ai trouvé la même tout à l'heure
Il y a peut-être tout le matériel de pique nique
C'est un pique nique qui a mal tourné ça
Ah t'as la fourchette toi
Allez
On trouve le couteau qui va avec sinon personne ne mange
C'est une pince à œillet ça
Ah oui pour faire des petits trous
Des petits trous, encore des petits trous
Tu veux un piercing ?
Vas y
Argh
Là si c'est quelque chose de bien
Vous devez déposer le petit pouce bleu
Il y a quelque chose
Oh une paire de ciseaux
Bon en vrai...
ça passe
C'est pas le TGV
La prochaine fois on vient en TER
regardez la cisaille
Bien Alex, le tas commence a être pas mal
Sachant qu'il y en a un peu de partout
On est bien sur une décharge des années 70 visiblement
Baptiste fait des bulles
Une soupape, faut trouver le moteur qui va avec
On a trouvé un passage sous ce pont
On va essayer de faire monter Rasta
Oui c'est bien
Pour redescendre on glissera
Allez
Il est génial ce passage secret
Nous sommes dans le pont, regardez comment Rasta marche
Il n'a peur de rien ce Rasta
C'est bien Rasta
C'est bien, t'es un grand
Bah alors pourquoi tu regardes Alex comme ça ?
Dès qu'il y a à manger il est là
On va utiliser la technique du double aimant
Il y en a un qui doit tirer son aimant dans le plot
Et l'autre à l'extérieur
Mais c'est impossible de tirer à l'intérieur là
Tu es bon ou tu n'est pas doué ?
Alors il faut le retourner d'abord, regarde
Je vais le retourner
Il approche, Quentin !
Là tu dois tirer d'un coup sec à l'intérieur
Il est encore propre ce plot
Pas loin
Ah... non
Tire de nouveau devant
Maintenant nous sommes passé par dessous...
Essaie de l'autre côté
Non dedans
Ouais vas y dedans si tu veux
C'est trop loin je pense
Ah si c'est bon
Attends
On croise alors, on échange
Il est parfait
C'est magnifique
Il manquait que ça dans la camionnette
Habituellement tu te les mets sur la tête non ?
Ah c'est vrai c'est la tradition, tu peux me tenir ça ?
Il est grand celui-là quand même
J'ai une petite tête
Il est trop gros...
Tu vas sentir bon maintenant
Troisième spot de la journée
vous êtes chauds ?
Non quatrième spot
Quatrième ouais
Coquin
T'étais ou ?
On est sous un pont qui a l'air bien remplis
C'est plein ici Baptiste
Je ne sais pas pour toi, mais moi j'ai plein de choses
Regardez ça
En un lancer
ça ça date sûrement de la construction du pont
Et ça c'est un guidon de petit vélo
De BMX
Ouais BMX
J'ai des trucs les amis
Regarde moi ça
La forme est étonnante
Ouais
C'est une hélice ?
Je pense plutôt à une manivelle
Ouais c'est un morceau de manivelle
Il manque le cercle autour
Ah oui d'accord
Alors qu'est-ce que Alex a trouvé ?
Un gros Laguiole
Ah oui ?
Ici c'est rare
Oh il est magnifique
Il est très beau, et en plus tu aimes bien les couteaux toi, c'est parfait
J'adore les couteaux
Il a eu ce qu'il voulait !
Il est tout propre
Effectivement
Très belle découverte
Il n'a aucun jeu en plus non ?
Non rien du tout
Tout beau tout neuf
Bien joué
Un beau Laguiole de meurtre ?
Le coin est très sympa
Il y a quelques nuages mais ça va
J'aime bien la forme de cette maison en face
C'est original
Ouais ça change des maisons de chez nous
Ils ont trouvé quoi un beau laguiole ?
Ouais Alex
ça se prononce Layole d'ailleurs, pardon
En plus il adore les couteaux
Et oui
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? Vous avez encore quelque chose ?
Oui quelque chose de génial
Je cours plus vite que toi !
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Woaw !
Une dague
Ah ouais !
Ouais c'est une dague
Elle est un peu tordue, mais grande
Fais attention à la façon dont tu manipules ça ahaha
C'est arabe ou indien ça ?
Ce n'est pas un jouet
Arabe ou indien ?
Moi j'aurais dis arabe avec la tressage
Ce n'est pas trop de la qualité
On ne va pas se mentir
C'est beau les couteaux !
Ou alors c'est une dague artisanale du Lot
On ne va pas l'abîmer mais bon
Propriété de Alex
Non il n'y aura pas de marquages
Non pas mon nom dessus !
Qu'est-ce qu'on a ici ?
C'est un levier
Et ça c'est une hache
La mini hache, tu peux aller leur montrer
Et ça c'est bien une sorte de levier
Si vous savez en commentaires ce que ça peut-être
Il faut le gratter mais il ne bougera jamais
Là j'ai quelque chose
Oh non il s'est coincé
ça vient
Ah c'est un panneau !
C'est un ancien
Ceux-là n'ont même plus cette forme de flèche
La flèche est bien différente maintenant
Tu as la date derrière normalement
C'est recherché, il y a des collectionneurs de panneaux anciens
Regarde la date derrière
Ah oui, 1972, je ne le pensais pas si ancien
1972, vas y doucement
C'est vraiment super ça
ici il y a une marque, on pourra peut-être la déchiffrer après nettoyage
C'est bien, c'est très rare d'en trouver des si anciens en bon état
ça a quel âge ? 30 ans
Ben non 50
Ah oui 72, pardon
50 ans le panneau
Ah j'ai un truc
C'est pas un morceau de lampadaire ?
Salut les pêcheurs
Salut
ça va et vous ?
ça va oui
Est-ce que vous avez une idée en commentaires ?
Moi je ne sais pas
C'est difficile à dire
Ouais, je dirais que c'est l'arrière d'un missile
Un missile V1 peut-être ? Ahaha
Attends je vais trouver
Peut-être sous les éclairages en forme de boule
Des anciens exemplaires
Vous êtes bloqués ?
Allez, 1,2,3
Vous dites go
ça a bougé
ça y est bien joué
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est que ce truc
Mais ça fait une heure qu'il m'embête
Regarde
Peut-être un morceau de barrière
C'est un câble téléphonique ou électrique non ?
Téléphonique oui
Allez sors le poteau téléphonique avec
Allez je te filme
On va voir ce qu'il y a au bout
Un cadavre, un cadavre
Je t'aide à tirer ?
Oui, vu le poids, pas un seul cadavre
Il y a tout le rouleau de fil, ou alors deux cadavres
Ou quelqu'un de gros
Je crois que c'est une barrière
Ah mince
c'est bon ça vient
La barrière c'est ok
Ah oui c'est un bout de la barrière du pont
Attends attends
On va libérer le câble
C'est bon on a le bout
On a tout sorti
Bien
ça n'avait rien à faire dans l'eau
Romain vient de trouver un autoradio
Avec tous les composants
Il n'est pas jeune
Pas jeune du tout même
T'es vraiment dans le vintage là
Ah la vache oui
Tu peux régler les fréquences mais tu ne peux même pas mettre de cassette
Les cassettes n'étaient pas encore sorties
Même ces trucs là, c'est quoi tout ça ?
Ouais c'est les fusibles
Tu avais ça aussi sur ton aimant, ça peut servir
Ah une douille
J'en ai plein des douilles, garde là
Allez je garde ça peut servir
La manivelle est reconstituée
Donc ça ça peut provenir d'un un réchaud
Plutôt que de l'éclairage publique
Cette vidéo de pêche à l'aimant touche à sa fin
Plein de découvertes sous ce pont, et il en reste encore, à refaire !
Regardez ils sont tous fatigués
Tout le monde es en mode repos, même Rasta
On va vous montrer tout ce qu'on a ramassé dans la voiture
Dîtes nous en commentaires si vous voulez voir la restauration des objets les plus sympas de la pêche du jour
Viens manger des croquettes
Regarde il mange
Oh non
Laisse il ne veut pas